um be a
xbb.1.5 has been detected in 29
countries so far there may be more as
sequencing becomes less and less
available at a global level it's
difficult for us to track each of these
subvariants of Omicron so it is part of
Omicron and as you've noted um it is it
is the most transmissible subvariant
that has been detected yet the reason
for this are the mutations that are
within this recombinant this subvariant
of Omicron allowing this virus to adhere
to the cell and replicate easily and we
are concerned about its growth advantage
in particular in some countries in
Europe and in the U.S in North America
particularly the Northeast part of the
United States where xbb.1.5 has rapidly
replaced other circulating variants our
technical Advisory Group for virus
Evolution discussed this uh yesterday at
their call which was really focused on
the circulation of SARS cov2 in China
but we did discuss this submariant in
particular because it is rapidly
replacing other subvariants in some
countries Our concern is how
transmissible it is it does have immune
Escape like we've seen with xbb but it
is one of another sub-variants of
Omicron that is in circulation and the
more this virus circulates the more
opportunities it will have to change we
do expect further waves of infection
around the world but that doesn't have
to translate into further waves of of
death because our countermeasures
continue to work
so that is something that is on our
radar the technical Advisory Group for
virus evolution is doing a risk
assessment specifically on the
subvariant which we hope to publish in
in the next couple of days but what we
can say is that it does have a growth
Advantage
um above all of the other subvariants so
far we don't have any data on severity
yet or on the clinical picture but we
also do not have an indication that
severity has changed with xbb.1.5 but
that is something that we are watching
very closely through studies and
experimental studies in the lab but also
in real world data when we look at
hospitalization rates around the world
among people who are infected with this
subvariant certainly issues in terms of
the criteria for recording and Reporting
debts attributable to covid-19 We
believe that definition is too narrow
which requires respiratory failure
association with over 19 to be
registered as a covert related death
that is a very narrow definition we know
there are difficulties in all countries
very often in recording Hospital related
Admissions and use of ICU facilities but
again we believe that the the current
number has been being published from
China underrepresents the true impact of
the disease in terms of Hospital
admissions in terms of ICU Admissions
and particularly in terms of debt we
continue to ask China for more rapid
regular reliable data on
hospitalizations and there's as well as
more comprehensive real-time viral
sequencing
who is concerned about the risk to life
in China and has reiterated the
importance of vaccination including
booster dose to protect against
hospitalization severe disease and death
this is especially important for older
people those with underlying medical
conditions and others who are at higher
risk of severe outcomes with circulation
in China so high and comprehensive data
are not forthcoming as I said last week
it's understandable that some countries
are taking steps they believe will
protect their own citizens
this data is useful to who in the world
and we encourage all countries to share
it
data remains essential for who to carry
out regular rapid and robust risk
assessments of the current situation and
I just Our advice and guidance
accordingly